hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game from round four of the
2021 us chess championship it's a game
that will surely improve your sunday as
it's a wonderful miniature but also it
will remind you how cruel chess can be
sometimes so without further ado it's
ray robson versus jeffrey xiong xiong
not having the uh the greatest
tournament so far lost his two previous
games robson is doing very very well uh
so let's see how how this game turns out
eruption with the white pieces uh opens
with e4 we have c5 by xion going for the
sicilian defense knight to f3 knight to
c6 and bishop to b5 now uh pretty much
everyone now goes for the ninja medina
over solemo attack uh we have e5 and now
uh white just castles uh we often
mentioned that you can't really go for
this spawn because it's uh well doesn't
matter what you capture with for example
the cameras knight captures queen d4
attacks the knight and the pawn so black
can win his pawn easily and equalize or
or even become better so here white just
castles and now bishop to d6 guarding
the pawn so for the moment uh the d-pawn
is blocked you can't really move it
but this is all uh worked out so you you
don't have to worry about it we have c3
now preparing to strike in the center
with d4 we have a6 challenging the
bishop bishop to a4 and b5 now now you
could go back to b3 then black will
attack it again and then to c2 or you
could go to c2 right away which is what
robson does we have knight to g to e7
now you can castle you can execute
f5 and now we have a4 now what we
usually do when black has a nice
expansion on the queen side we of course
undermine it with a pawn push like a4
black plays b4 and now rook to e1 so the
black king is still in the center of the
board and you should uh consider
castling
at some point but maybe if you castle
now then d4 can be
somewhat annoying uh but also uh instead
of castling just queen to c7 is a known
move here so you could play that you you
could play anything here really but in
the game knight the g6 was played by
xiong and it is now as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game so white says
all right since your king is still in
the center of the board uh let's for the
moment keep it there we're going to play
d4 and now usually black will just
capture on d4 when white plays this but
here we have a b captures on c3 and this
gives white an idea
on how to keep the black king in the in
the center of the board a little bit
longer first d captures an e5 and now
already there's a problem because your
bishop on d6 is hanging so you have to
do something about this but first c
captures on b2 we're going to go after
white to rook on a1 so bishop captures
on b2 and now again black's bishop on b6
is hanging in you have to decide whether
you want to go for the pawn or do you
want to play bishop back to c7 bishop
back the c7 or even e7 are the safe
choices here uh but xiong boldly goes
for the pawn he plays bishop captures on
e5 and now we have knight captures on e5
knight g captures on e5 bishop captures
knight captures and now queen to d5
after this capture fest we go after the
knight and the rook on a8 so still
keeping the black king in the center of
the board knight to c6 is the only move
that parries both threats so knight to
c6 and only now we claim our pawn back
so queen captures on c5 uh prevents the
black king from castling so what do you
do here
well you could try bishop to d7
continuing development but it's uh very
hard to leave your king in the center of
the board like this so xiang offers a
queen trade with queen to e7 and robson
just trades we have queen captures king
captures now saying that i'm not uh
interested in castling the queens are of
the board better to keep my king in the
center of the board
for more activity and okay knight to c3
we want to get this knight to d5 it's an
excellent square and the black plays
knight to b for kind of stopping this uh
but also attacking the bishop on c2 so
knight to d5 check we're still gonna
play this
uh now you have to capture the knight
otherwise uh you're gonna lose the
knight on b4 so knight captures on d5e
captures on the e5 opening up a
discovery from the rook and now do you
go back or do you go uh forward with
something like king to d6 king to d6
could be
uh maybe a little bit too much because
even though you go after this pawn let's
say we play rook eight to b1 wha what is
your king really doing on d6 if you
capture the pawn bishop to e4 check
loses the rook here so
although it's possible to go king to d6
it looks a bit too adventurous so king
back to d8 was played you don't want to
play king to e8 because you really want
to develop this rook so king 28 is the
only option here and now comes d6 we
reach the position from the thumbnail
and now you can see how it's not all
that easy for for black to continue
developing for example if bishop to b7
we can go after the bishop rook a to b1
and in bishop to c6 we play rook to e7
it's uh uh going after this pawn and the
white will always be more active and
better in this uh position so instead
after d6 white played a5 maybe with the
idea of developing the bishop to this
long diagonal so now bishop to d3 we
stopped this
and we have many many options here to
continue the the game with the rook so
here we have rook to b8 bishop to a6 the
move that was kind of planned here still
works we can just play bishop to a6
trade bishops and go for this kind of an
end game for example bishop to a6 now
white trades for example captures
captures and now you can play even rook
to b1 you don't have to worry about this
capture because you might blunder the
rook here so it's never easy for black
to deal with this d6 pawn and it really
restrains the the movements of the black
king
but in the game after bishop to d3 rook
to b8 was played and now robson just
goes for rook a to b1 now goes after the
rook here and what do you play here uh
the problem with just trading for
example although of course it can be
played rook captures rook captures uh
what do you play now you always have to
worry about ideas like rook to b8 bishop
to a6 going after this c8 bishop your
king can't really move and if you play
rook to e8 you want to really activate
it now we're going to play g3 not allow
any back rank ideas and after i move
like rook to e5 now we're going to play
rook to b8 of course we're going to
threaten bishop to a6 so rook to c5
adding a defender here and now bishop to
a6 and now it seems like black defended
the rook is out of the game but this
king can never go anywhere the bishop
can't move and the rook has to keep an
eye on the bishop at all times and now
it's um
not that difficult for whites to make
progress for example rook c6 we can just
kick away the rook we don't really care
if rook back to c1 check we can just
play here and now black is pretty much
stuck making moves with the rook and
we're just gonna start improving the
position over king for example king here
doesn't really matter how many times you
check us uh now we finally get to d5 and
we trade everything here captures
captures captures captures king c5 we're
going to pick up this pawn and easily
win the king and pawn end game
so that's the problem with uh the the
black king being stuck like this and
it's very easily for whites to
completely pin down black's pieces so
here we have rooked the b7 uh xiung says
all right if you capture i can now
nicely
uh just uh you know develop my light
square bishop and of course i don't have
to worry about moves like uh bishop to
a6 because i just capture on b1 and
after you capture i can simply win a
piece here so after rook to b7 we have
rook eat the c1 now putting more
pressure here on black's queen side and
now you don't really have any other
options now you have to capture here and
then you know continue playing uh
similar to the line that we just
discussed but now okay the affair rooks
is off the board for example rook to e8
g3 and now after rook the e6 going after
the pawn we're going to play rook to b6
and
black is uh
fighting but the white white is still
better however after rook eat the c1 uh
xiong played rook to b4 saying now okay
if you capture i'm gonna have a passport
on b4 already uh but this move uh
allows the white to go for a very very
tricky idea so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on achieving this
beautiful sunday miniature and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's of course rook captures on b4 yes
it's seems simple
but uh you know
it it just works the problem is the past
a pawn will be unstoppable so a captures
on b4 now a5 was played with bishop to
b7 if you try bringing the rook into the
game because you really want to do this
for the entire game it's too slow we're
going to play a6 rook to e5 now try and
get behind the pawn but now rook to a1
and there's no stopping the past pawn
that's just game so instead after a5
bishop the b7 was played at least you
can put your bishop on a8 to prevent the
promotion
a6 now as the bishop already nicely
covers this bishop to a8 and now a7 and
it was in this position on move 28 that
jeffrey xiong resigned the game uh and a
wonderful victory for ray robson in
round four of the united states chess
championship and this means that he is
now the sole leader after four rounds uh
followed by i think uh five or six
people are on two and a half points he's
the the only one on three points and
here you resign because there is no
defense whatever you play here well
there really isn't all that much you can
play you can maybe try and bring the
rook into the game now we're just going
to play bishop to a6 and how do you stop
this checkmate there's no way to do it
uh if you play bishop to c6 we just
temporarily temporarily sacrifice a
queen of course this is with the check
so it's forced after bishop captures
we're going to deliver rook to c8
checkmate and that's it uh so really
a wonderful uh wonderful uh miniature
that went horribly bad for black very
very quickly but uh you know that's uh
that's just the thing and you should
never underestimate a move like uh
let me just rewind a little bit this
move like d6 it's a such a powerful move
it seems like maybe you've advanced it a
bit too much because you have a light
square bishop and this is now a dark
square however you're going to defend it
if the black rooks go after it but
that's just it the black rooks will
never be able to go after it and uh just
the crippling the the black king like
this is uh what uh made this miniature
possible because even though probably
xion could have played a little bit
better it's so so difficult to find the
moves in positions like these uh when
your opponent just completely stifles
you so maybe something to keep in mind
you know maybe to use in your own games
and we'll you know see what happens uh
but yeah that's the game uh
congratulations to ray robson for this
uh brilliant win and for taking lead in
the us chess championship 2021 uh i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to natalia and i would like to thank
olga the dinosaur david kimura ravindra
jagalkar
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the us chess championship
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you i will see
you soon and have an excellent sunday